ich zum beispiel jetzt sage wenn dieses
video 1500 daumen hoch kriegt kommt
morgen direkt noch eine sieht
vorstellung dann sage ich morgen zum
beispiel wenn dieses video 1600 daumen
hoch krieg dann kommt die nächsten tag
wieder eine vorstellung hallo ich ihn
freuen und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen sieht vorstellung und zwar wollte
ich euch ganz gut sagen dass musik
vorstellungen zur zeit eigentlich mit am
meisten spaß machen von allen projekten
die ich so habe ich habe jetzt nicht
viel aber von mod reviews von texture
pack vorstellungen von adventure maps
oder ganz neuen pvp sachen machen wir
eigentlich sieht vorstellungen mit am
meisten spaß deswegen habe ich mir eine
sache überlegt die wir eventuell auf die
beine stellen könnten
und zwar versuche ich ja immer öfter
einfach sieht vorstellungen zu machen
und da das immer so ein bisschen dauert
weil man muss ich dir aussuchen dann
irgendwie im internet oder halt auch mal
selber aussuchen und man muss sich dann
halt vorbereiten wo die ganzen sachen
sind was man dazu sagt halt solche
sachen sie zwar immer relativ kurz aus
sondern video aber es natürlich schon
arbeit und deswegen wollte ich einfach
fragen ob ihr bock an seiner serie hätte
ok sieht vorstellungen mache ich jetzt
natürlich schon aber dass ich zum
beispiel jetzt sage wenn dieses video
1500 daumen hoch kriegt kommt morgen
direkt noch eine zielvorstellung dann
sage ich morgen zum beispiel wenn dieses
video 1600 daumen hoch kriegt dann kommt
der nächsten tag wieder eine vorstellung
also dass er quasi durch diese
bewertungen bzw
allgemein durch eure aktivität zeigt
dass ihr mehr zieht vorstellungen haben
wollt dann könnt ihr einfach den daumen
hoch geben und wenn das dann jetzt zb 15
k oder 1000 bewundert daumen hoch hat
dann kommt morgen direkt nochmal eine
sieht vorstellungen und dann immer so
weiter und wenn das dann irgendwann halt
ich weiß nicht wie hoch richter gehen
kann also keine ahnung also ich werde
einfach schauen wie lange ich das
durchziehen kann
weil die klausurphase ist vorbei ich
habe auf jeden fall die zeit zu machen
wenn ihr daran auch bock habt dann gebt
einfach den daumen hoch dass sich dann
auch daran und dann schauen wir mal was
daraus wird also ich wäre auf jeden fall
bereit dann täglich eine vorstellung zu
machen müssen wir einfach schauen wie
das bei euch ankommt
so und jetzt kommt erstmal zum ersten
zieht und zwar gegen den singleplayer
world nenne ich sie
2 keine ahnung egal
creative und geht hier einfach diesem
zieht eines -9 0 57 35 26 51 117 54 08
31 wir bilden uns einfach das terrain
hier blablabla und dieser sieg hat zwar
geil keine genialen landschaften
allerdings wort habt ihr habt ihr so ein
bisschen holz als ganz ganz schönes
millionen finde ich eigentlich sofort
ihrer kür am start und sohn und zwar
haben wir hier in fetten ozean also vom
terra normal findet jetzt zwar nicht so
schön aber doch ich finde schön
vielleicht sind die meisten von euch
nicht schön aber ich stehe auf solche
sachen allerdings was wir haben ist dass
wir hier eine revier haben wir gesehen
was da drin ist und hier allerdings ist
die erst mal ein bisschen uninteressant
das einzig interessante ist dass ihr uns
weil ich lass mich dann einfach
runterfallen wartet vielleicht schaffe
ich sogar bis dahin getrieben zu werden
bedeute wahrscheinlich nicht
wir haben hier unten instant diamond
zurzeit wir haben direkt sechs diamanten
waren es glaube ich 123456 genau sechs
diamanten hier hinten sind noch mehr
diamanten also ich es noch 12 345 also
bisher elf diamanten ich weiß nicht ich
glaube hier hinten waren noch mehr
diamant hier hier drin war oder bringt
als hab ich kein bock durch
da sind noch mehr die haben und ich
glaube insgesamt sind das hier unten 15
diamanten ich sage jetzt einfach mal elf
weil elf habe ich euch ja zeigen können
deswegen ich möchte die lügen elfte
jemand auf jeden fall direkt zu finden
direkt am sport ihr müsst euch daran
erinnern hier ist die revue ihr könnt
euch da erst mal ein paar holz sachen
holen und bevor ihr die meisten
minecraft spieler ich zb brauchen ca 10
milliarden 1100 million parts um
diamanten zu finden bzw
das end zu erreichen das bauen wir hier
sagt ersten diamanten und ihr seht ihr
wisst ja das ziel vor meint es das end
zu erreichen und den nenner drachen zu
besiegen
hier ist es franck also zack wir können
quasi direkt hier noch in der ersten
nacht das spiel vollenden wenn wir uns
ganz schön anstrengend wir haben holz
wir haben diamanten können so rüstung
machen und so was als also hier sind ein
paar kisten bücher und wir haben dann
hier auch bei sollte kann man nicht
einfach mal so einfach mit wir haben
natürlich dann hier auch diese
kompletten stronghold jazz dingsbums
dungeons keine ahnung ob man war das
nicht unten das war jedoch ebenso
verändern sich die strukturen von welt
zu welt nicht glaubt nicht aber dann hab
ich mich gerade verteilen sich entlang
gelaufen also alles ein bisschen brüchig
hier weil ich mich schuldig dass man wir
sind hier mit einer höhle
da kann man nicht erwarten dass die
architekten die das ganze errichtet
haben das alles hier wunderschön
gestaltet haben weil da sind natürlich
auch eine menge erdlöcher in bodenhöhe
nicht was da dahinter als geglänzt dass
du das war einfach so eine fackel wie
ihr seht schon hier sind auf jeden fall
eine menge krasse sachen also direkt 11
diamanten zwei wiens eine menge holz
sogar der landschaft unseren stronghold
also das ist echt ein hammer sieht wenn
ihr dann wollt dass morgen es sofort
weitergeben in der nächsten zeit
vorstellung dann gebt dem video wie
gesagt einfach den daumen hoch wenn wir
bei 15 kommen dann hieße kiste die
könnte es theoretisch werfen
anleger brauchen in der affäre geht wie
gesagt dann schreibt ein schrank
gefahren daumen hoch da kommt eventuell
morgen die nächste schicht vorstellen
und dann sehen wir uns warum mache ich
das eigentlich immer das wird ihn nie
schwarz davon